This is a special video today we're
talking about a topic that heavily
affects both this channel and in general
all of Youtube as a platform,
but don't worry,
nobody is shutting down this channel,
but maybe those of us who watched from
the European Union will no longer be
able to watch some videos yesterday were
talking about article 13,
something you might have heard of it,
especially if you live in Europe because
youtube seems to have replaced all of my
youtube ads which were previously.
Would you love a chocolate bar with
something related to article 13?
Now,
let's quickly make one thing clear here.
We definitely biased,
but that's probably not a huge surprise
to you.
In fact,
we're playing an active role in this
matter.
One member of the visual holistic team
was in Brussels recently talking about
article 13 with policymakers who are
currently negotiating it.
That by the way,
it would be Fonseca also known as the
drunk Spanish guy doing the voiceovers
in some of the earlier episodes.
According to some comments.
Yeah.
To this day,
there is an association representing
European online creators.
This is why a group of European Youtube
channels decided to take a bit of an
initiative and show our concerns,
do the relevant politicians,
visual politic.
We were one of them,
so for those who don't know,
it's article 13 is part of an EU
directive which aims to regulate
copyright online,
but the question is now,
well,
what exactly is article 13?
Is it as terrible as everyone is saying
and most important of all,
what can we content creators do about
this?
Well,
today we're going to answer all of these
questions,
but before we do,
as always,
let's take a look back at the history
for me for the last few years answering
the what do you do for a living
question?
I kind of got sort of complicated.
Some people,
especially maybe the oldest,
they tend to think,
oh,
well that's nice dear,
but you know what you do for actual
money.
Some of them I've just given up on.
I'm pretty sure that my grandma thinks
I'm a television presenter here in
Prague.
Okay.
But the answer is yes,
I make a living doing this and it's
probably not all that surprising to all
of you millennials watching.
Now we British,
we don't like talking about money.
Indeed.
Fun factor were seven times more likely
to tell someone we've had an std that we
all to reveal our income to the
awkwardness.
Let's just take visual politic.
Both the English and the Spanish version
combines.
They get about 10 million views a month
and as you can imagine,
this translates in do something.
You know,
it's a lot of people watching now.
No visual politic.
It doesn't make us millionaires,
but along with the Patriot on donations,
thank you very much.
And the ads,
we can all draw a decent salary and
look,
we're not the only ones.
There aren't thousands of creators just
like us all across Europe,
creators,
enough of an audience to make an income
and even create new jobs.
And that's only youtube.
It also happens on other platforms like
instagram and facebook and twitch.
This means that online creators,
we've become an industry.
I mean it's not exactly an oil and gas,
but it does exist.
It's an industry that employs thousands
of people in Europe and creates value
for society most of the time.
Yes.
Youtube might be an American company,
but the world's biggest youtube.
That's Pewdie Pie I think.
Hold on.
Yes,
go Pewdie Pie.
He is still beating t series and he's
Swedish.
Alright,
so what exactly is the problem then?
Well,
like I said,
there is no association that represents
US creators,
media corporations in record labels and
they've got trade associations and
they've even got big lobbies in
Brussels.
We don't why?
Well,
mainly because we started out little by
little.
The story behind every youtuber is
pretty much the same.
You start small,
make a few videos,
hopefully you see a bit of growth and
then suddenly you can be like,
oh,
I do this as a job.
And as you can imagine during this
process,
as someone who's been through this
I haven't.
And I imagine most people don't think at
any point now I should create a trade
association,
you know,
just in case one day the European Union
is like,
let's introduce a big old directive that
really affects these people.
It's just something that doesn't come
across on mine.
Alright,
so at this point it's probably important
for you to know exactly how copyright
works in Europe.
Well,
to this day we're under these so called
ecommerce directive and also the
copyright directive.
Both of these were passed back in 2001
so.
Well,
how does this legislation work?
let's imagine that I upload a video to
visual politic and I use a video clip
from a band.
So let's say I upload a song by the band
Tasmania who often provide music for
this channel,
but let's assume I upload their song
without permission.
This means I'm actually created
something illegal Tasmania role.
The record label who holds their rights
can then sue me.
This means that essentially they can
request a big fine from me.
And do they do it well?
Probably not.
I'm a pretty small creator in my
pockets.
I'll just not that deep so well.
What can Tasmania do?
Well,
they can go to youtube and they can ask
them to take down the video.
Indeed,
this process is often mostly automatic.
Youtube actually has a tool that small
filter called content id.
In this case,
Tasmania would send all of the
information about their on to youtube.
This way youtube can scan the platform
looking for that song.
Anytime they find it,
they can take down the offending video.
This is how the law works.
Well,
that's all fine and that's all that
good,
but just
hold on a second because this is where
the interesting part comes in.
Now it says mania can pretty much ask
youtube,
hey youtube,
how about instead of just taking that
video down,
your slice me off a bit,
a sweet sweet revenue pie and send it my
way.
Now according to the letter of the law,
Youtube doesn't have to block the song
if requested,
but the law doesn't say anything about
paying licenses,
which is essentially what Tasmania
wants.
Nonetheless,
since youtube is apparently pretty
chill,
they want to do business with Tasmania,
so they essentially say,
all right,
then what we'll do is we'll negotiate a
license,
we'll give you a little slice and
everyone's happy.
Sounds good,
and otherwise they've negotiated a
contract and now you might be wondering,
well,
how big is that slice of the revenue
pie?
Well,
according to the record labels,
it's pretty low.
Just consider what economy.
Some user upload content platforms
refused to compensate artists and all
music creators fairly for their work.
While they exploited it for their own
profit.
Sir Paul Mccartney,
the question now is,
is Paul Mccartney,
right or wrong?
Youtube states they give to the majority
of the revenue to the record label,
but we don't really know because the
labels want to keep this information
confidential.
We also don't know because,
well we asked them and nobody would tell
us.
There is one thing we do know though,
the European music associations like
IFP,
why or impala,
they want youtube to pay more.
They claim there is a so called value
gap between the Revenue Youtube
generates and what they pay them.
In other words,
they want to have a stronger negotiation
position and how can they do that?
Well,
that would be with a new copyright law
that forces platforms like youtube to
pay a license.
This is why in the year 2016,
the European Commission wrote the first
draft for this
direct
Dev on copyright in the digital single
market.
According to this law,
Youtube and the rest of the user
generated content platforms,
ms dot compensate fairly to create us.
This means that youtube doesn't give
that added percentage because they're
chill,
but rather because they're legally
compelled to.
And this is a big deal.
This means that the record labels have a
better negotiating position.
Alright,
so so far all of this,
it doesn't actually sound that terrible.
So just hold on a moment though because
this is where things get really
complicated.
Devil is in the details as you might or
might not know,
the European Commission itself cannot
pass the law.
They have to send it first to the
European Parliament and vendor,
the European Council.
These two institutions,
they have to write their own versions of
the Lauren.
This is where the real issue with
article 13 comes up.
Online content sharing service providers
perform an act of communication to the
public.
Article Thirteen,
paragraph one,
EU parliament vision.
All right,
so now you might be thinking,
all right,
Simon,
what is up?
Where exactly is the problem?
What does it mean for you?
I really do need to translate what we
just heard from the language of the
European Parliament.
It basically means Youtube would have
unlimited liability on the content that
stays on that platform to illustrate the
impact of this.
Let's go back to Tasmania band example.
Now they couldn't do see me.
They could also sue me and youtube and
remember that I mentioned the deep
pockets swell.
Youtube appsolutely has those other
words.
According to this legislation,
youtube would have to spend millions in
losses.
Just think about it because there's such
a huge quantity of video going up to
youtube and need over 300 hours of
videos are uploaded every minute.
The chances are many of those videos can
have some sort of copyright violation
and youtube just needs to have one video
with a copyright issue to give them a
potentially multi million dollar legal
headache.
Now obviously youtube cannot deal with
that kind of legal exposure,
so they have to find a way to avoid it
and how do they do that?
Well,
they have to build a wall,
in this case,
a very strict firewall.
Basically any video with third party
content would have to be blocked.
Of course,
if you're in America,
you could still watch it because this
law only affects content watched or
uploaded inside Europe.
So if this gets passed,
well,
good luck trying to watch videos inside
of European.
Yeah,
union
and I'm not just talking about people
who are purposefully violating copyright
here.
I'm talking about most videos because
it's really hard to work out what is and
what.
It's not third party content.
In fact,
it's pretty much almost impossible.
Basically everything just beyond a dude
talking to a camera with a white
backgrounds would have a risk of being
blocked and.
Well,
that actually includes this video
because right now I'm going to show you
a quote from Donald Trump on CNN.
I think you should let me run the
country.
You run CNN and if you did it well,
your ratings,
if I may ask the question was present
from it and I know what you're going to
say.
You're probably thinking,
well,
come on son.
You haven't done anything illegal there.
I mean that's got to be fair use,
right?
And yes,
you're absolutely right.
According to the law,
I can use content in this manner for
Satta an illustration,
but you know what?
That youtube firewall isn't a lawyer.
It's an algorithm and algorithms don't
understand content store the law,
so there's brand new youtube far.
Well,
we'll just say whoa.
Third Party content,
block it and last Vance and the same
goes for when I show you this clip from
Tasmania.
Your
is this a legal?
No,
but good luck trying to make a robot
understands legal caveats and really all
of my youtube creator comrades watching
this video are going to agree with me
that there are many problems with the
filters on youtube already.
So imagine how tough it is going to be
when there's an even more aggressive
firewall,
but hold on a moment because it's not
all bad news.
There is an alternative indeed,
there is a solution.
It's a solution that makes everybody
moderately happy and that is actually
pretty realistic.
Can it be done about this?
As I told you before,
this copyright directive has been voted
on in the European parliaments,
but this doesn't mean the legislation
has been passed.
In fact,
we're still in the middle of it all.
You see the process to pass an EU
directive,
it goes as follows.
First step,
the European Commission creates a first
draft.
That's how we got the first version of
article 13.
Second step.
This draft goes to the EU parliament.
They write another draft and they vote
on it.
This is why we have another version of
article 13,
but now there is a third step and a
third player coming in and that's the
European Council.
So
the European Council is where all of the
member states are represented and Oh
yes,
they have approved another veteran of
article 13,
so yes,
dear view is we don't just have what our
for 13,
we actually have three different
versions.
One from the commission,
Waterford,
the parliament and one from the council.
European political institutions are so
simple,
said no one ever so.
Well.
What happens next?
Well,
now we are in the third step,
which is when the condition,
the parliaments and the council,
they get together and they negotiate in
Brussels speak.
This is cooled of the trial logs
and yes,
that is sort of a dialogue,
but with three people,
like I said,
things are never simple in Brussels.
Even the words they use,
so let's imagine a big room with a big
round table.
On the one hand we have the commission
representative and our advisors on the
other.
We have the representative of the
parliaments and on the other we have the
one from the council counseling all of
the representatives and advisors.
We have over 30 people negotiating.
They meet almost every week and you
better believe me,
it is a long process which probably
doesn't surprise you.
In this case we have three different
texts and believe me,
the one from the council is very
different.
The absence of the authorization and
online content sharing provider shall
not be liable for the acts of the
communication to the public when it
demonstrates that it has made its best
efforts and upon notification by rights
holders,
it has acted expedia mostly to remove or
disable access to these works.
Article 13,
paragraph four.
All right.
Let me translate that for you.
This means that youtube is liable for
the content on their platform,
but the liability is missing.
Jesus still,
we might need to clarify what that
means,
so let's get back to the Tasmania.
For example,
with this new lauren hand,
Youtube must report to them the songs
that are uploaded on the platform and
they have to ask them whether they want
to take the video down or get a license
from it.
At this moment,
Tasmania will have to add their data and
metadata into a form.
This way,
that filter youtube already has these so
called content ID system already knows
what to track,
but not only that,
according to this article 13 version,
if youtube shows they have done
everything possible to protect the
copyright,
they cannot be sued.
In other words,
if youtube plays by the rules,
they can avoid a lot of legal
uncertainty.
Now,
yes,
they would have to pay more money to the
record labels,
but there's no existential risk anymore,
and of course we.
Their content creators would also be
happy to because we didn't have to worry
about all of our videos being blocked.
And finally,
of course,
the record labels are happy as well
because they get what they need.
Better conditions for negotiating.
So let me quickly summarize for you
what's the difference between the
parliament and the council positions?
The consequences of the parliaments of
Ashton is that European youtube would
just become another TV channel.
One of the creators you already have a
big audience would survive.
Why?
Because they're the only ones you can
pay a lawyer to manage all of the
copyright issue so that Youtube will let
them upload videos,
but there's going to be a pretty big
pool and it's going to be pretty
impossible to surpass for the hundreds
of thousands of small creators,
but there is a way to find a common
ground for all of the players here,
and of course it's compromise and
compromise.
That's what politics is all about.
So now the big question is,
well,
what comes after this step?
What is the fourth step here?
While officer,
this legislation has been negotiated by
the trial logs.
They bring it back to the parliaments
that they vote yes or no on the text and
then we go to the final step.
And this is an EU directive.
Now an EU directive is not actually a
law,
but it's rather a guideline.
So after the director of gets passed,
it has to go to all of the member states
where they turn it international laws,
and this is another moment where online
creators have to show up and speak to
their national governments.
And yes,
if you're a European youtube creator
watching this right now,
that includes you.
So if there's one thing that we learned
from our trip to Brussels is kind of the
policymakers,
they don't even know you exist,
and if they don't know about us as an
industry,
if they don't know that thousands of
people live off creating content online,
they will not understand how many people
might get unemployed because of a bad
regulation.
So if you liked this video,
rather than asking you to subscribe
today,
I suggest that you share it with a
friend as a creator of Fanny European,
hopefully someone who will help make a
difference.
Now at some point in the future,
we're probably going to need to act on
this.
And here are visual politic.
We're going to keep you posted and thank
you for watching.
And if you've enjoyed hearing my lovely
voice,
consider checking out the dreams around
the world youtube channel for more on
travel psychology and personal
development.